Vous avez probablement déjà entendu dire
de quelqu’un qu’il est « cartésien ».
On connaît aussi des personnages de fiction
dont on a envie de dire qu’ils sont cartésiens.
Sherlock Holmes, par exemple, pour sa capacité
à trouver très logiquement la solution de
ses enquêtes.
De même, le docteur House, qui grâce à
sa grande capacité de déduction, parvient
à identifier des maladies rares et insoupçonnées.
Ou encore, Tony Stark, l’homme derrière
le héros Iron Man, pour sa capacité à inventer
des technologies adaptées à ses problèmes.
Une personne cartésienne, ça serait donc
de prime abord une personne intelligente et
rationnelle.
Mais est-ce qu’on aurait vraiment besoin
d’un adjectif faisant référence au philosophe
Descartes pour dire seulement ça, l’intelligence
et la rationalité ?
Eh bien non, parce que le sens de l’adjectif
« cartésien » est plus précis.
Je suis Romain, et vous êtes sur 1000 idées
de culture générale, la chaîne qui parle
du meilleur de la pensée sans vous prendre
la tête.
On utilise l’adjectif « cartésien » en
référence à la fameuse méthode de Descartes
exposée dans son Discours de la méthode,
celle qui est à l’origine des sciences
modernes.
Le but de Descartes, c’était de rompre
avec la scolastique, la philosophie chrétienne
du Moyen Âge, trop spéculative à son goût,
pour fonder la recherche de la connaissance
sur des bases plus fermes.
Sa méthode s’inspire notamment des mathématiques
afin de préserver le raisonnement de l’erreur.
Être cartésien, c’est donc raisonner selon
cette méthode.
Mais qu’est-ce que ça veut dire plus précisément
? Je vais vous l’expliquer en 3 points.
Être cartésien, c’est tout d’abord douter
: ne rien admettre sans examen, et ne jamais
considérer une vérité comme définitive.
Le cartésien a besoin de preuves et il est
par nature plutôt sceptique.
Pourquoi douter à ce point ? Parce que la
connaissance peut être détériorée par
un défaut de mémoire, par l’imagination,
ou encore par des préjugés transmis par
l’éducation ou par l’expérience.
Le cartésien doute parce qu’il ne veut
pas prendre le risque de se tromper : il veut
mettre à l’épreuve les opinions afin de
parvenir à une vérité solide.
C’est pour ça qu’il teste ses hypothèses
; qu’il vérifie et revérifie ses résultats.
Alors, je ne vais pas m’étendre plus en
détail sur ce qu’est le doute cartésien,
car ça sera l’objet d’une autre vidéo.
Il y a en fait une dimension encore plus importante
dans un esprit cartésien.
Être cartésien, c’est surtout raisonner
avec ordre.
Mais qu’est-ce que ça veut dire « raisonner
avec ordre » ?
Ça veut dire conduire sa pensée d’un objet
au suivant, en une suite de termes dont le
suivant dépend toujours du précédent.
L’ordre est donc par essence justifié : le
cartésien ne précipite pas sa réflexion,
il se focalise sur l’étape présente parce
qu’il sait qu’elle est la condition du
passage à l’étape suivante.
Je ne sais pas si vous vous souvenez du format
des démonstrations de mathématiques du collège
ou du lycée : on posait des hypothèses,
puis on descendait par enchaînements logiques
en utilisant les conjonctions « d’où » et
« donc ».
Eh bien, être cartésien, c’est plaquer
cette manière de raisonner sur toute question.
Ce n’est pas pour rien que Descartes nous
encourage à faire des maths, mais pour nous
habituer aux procédés de sa méthode !
L’ordre qui anime l’esprit cartésien
est donc semblable à l’ordre de la réflexion
mathématique.
Mais Descartes ne s’est pas arrêté là
: il a également donné des précisions sur
ce que devaient être les étapes elles-mêmes
d’une réflexion rigoureuse.
La méthode de Descartes repose plus précisément
sur 4 règles.
Alors, je ne dis pas qu’il faut les suivre
à la lettre pour mériter le qualificatif
de « cartésien », mais il est assez probable
qu’on les retrouve souvent dans la réflexion
d’un esprit cartésien.
Allez, voici ces 4 règles.
La première, c’est celle de l’évidence
: pour être sûr d’avoir affaire à l’évidence,
il faut se prémunir contre les deux tendances
de l’esprit humain, le préjugé et la précipitation.
Être cartésien, c’est donc dans le détail
se méfier des idées toutes faites et ne
pas conclure trop vite.
La deuxième règle, c'est celle de la simplification.
En effet, quand on reçoit les données d’un
problème, c’est souvent obscur ou confus
; c’est pour ça que Descartes recommande
de décomposer ces données en éléments
les plus simples possible, afin de pouvoir
mieux les examiner.
Être cartésien, c’est donc investir du
temps pour clarifier le problème avant d’en
chercher la solution.
La troisième règle, c’est celle de l’ordre.
Une fois que les éléments du problème apparaissent
plus clairement, il faut les ranger du plus
simple au plus complexe.
Je l’ai déjà dit de manière plus générale
: être cartésien, c’est réfléchir avec
ordre.
Enfin, la quatrième règle, c'est celle de
l’exhaustivité.
Comme l’esprit humain fait beaucoup d’erreurs,
il faut finir par mettre en doute son propre
raisonnement.
Pour le clore, en pratique, il faut le vérifier
entièrement, en passer en revue tous les
éléments afin de ne rien oublier.
Être cartésien, c’est donc avoir l’esprit
vérificateur, y compris avec ses propres
raisonnements.
Alors, je résume : les règles de la méthode
cartésienne que l’on doit retrouver dans
l’esprit cartésien, ce sont l’établissement
de l'évidence, la simplification, l’ordre,
et l’exhaustivité.
Être cartésien, c’est donc douter, réfléchir
avec ordre, et peut-être même plus précisément
suivre les 4 règles indiquées par Descartes.
Alors, être ou ne pas être cartésien ?
D’un côté, ça peut sembler un peu sec
comme attitude intellectuelle.
On dirait qu’être cartésien, c’est un
peu raisonner comme un programme informatique
- on est loin de l’épanouissement tiré
de la créativité artistique, là.
Mais de l’autre, ça ressemble plutôt à
un idéal bien nécessaire, tant l’esprit
humain est prompt à l’erreur et à se laisser
entraîner par les passions.
Je rappelle que le projet de Descartes n'était
pas tuer l’émotion, mais de dissiper les
chimères de la théologie du Moyen Âge et
de guider l’homme pour qu’il puisse faire
un meilleur usage de sa raison.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, mettez un pouce
bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire ma synthèse concernant la méthode
de Descartes sur le site 1000 idées de culture
générale, voire pour pour lire l’ouvrage
le Discours de la méthode, les liens sont
dans la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisées dans le format le
plus clair possible, vous pouvez vous inscrire
à la newsletter en laissant votre adresse
e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous vous n’avez pas besoin de
vous prendre la tête pour vous intéresser
au meilleur de la pensée.